un réseau social qui est rapidement
devenu incontournable l'application
compte plus d'un milliard d'utilisateurs
mais dorénavant les fonctionnaires
fédéraux ne pourront plus y accéder
depuis leur téléphone professionnel il y
a maintenant assez de préoccupations
qu'on va exiger que les téléphones de
travail des employés du gouvernement
fédéral nous pourront plus accéder
l'appli TikTok à cause des
préoccupations de sécurité des
préoccupations de sécurité qui
s'expliquent par le fait que
l'accompagnie mère de Tik Tok soit basée
en Chine le Canada en boîte ainsi le pas
à d'autres pays comme les États-Unis ou
l'administration Biden vient de donner
30 jours aux agences gouvernementales
pour se débarrasser du réseau social
dans l'Union européenne non plus pas de
Tik Tok pour les fonctionnaires une
enquête est aussi en cours pour
déterminer si l'entreprise a enfin la
Loi sur la protection des données on
n'est pas dans une situation qui est qui
est unique cette expert en cybersécurité
rappelle que Tic-Toc n'est pas le
premier réseau social à être critiqué
pour la gestion des données personnelles
la crainte selon lui est davantage
géopolitique qu'informatique cette
compagnie là est installée en Chine et
donc et sous le contrôle où j'irai de
les demandes d'accès aux données du
gouvernement chinois donc même si Tik
Tok disait on a des on met en place des
serveurs au Canada j'aurais toujours un
risque que le gouvernement demande à
accéder à des copies de certaines
données dans un courriel Tik Tok c'est
dit déçu par la décision du Canada nous
sommes toujours disponibles pour
rencontrer le gouvernement et expliquer
ce que nous faisons pour protéger la vie
privée des Canadiens de l'entreprise
si c'est toi qui est interdit sur les
téléphones du gouvernement fédéral le
grand public lui a toujours accès
comme les politiciens qui sont de plus
en plus nombreux à utiliser le réseau
social mais n'y cherchez pas à Pierre
poilliev le chef conservateur qui était
jusqu'à présent très actif sur Tik Tok à
désactiver son compte dans la journée
tout comme le reste de son cocus qui
veut maintenant que l'interdiction soit
étendue aux appareils parlementaires ici
Radio-Canada Montréal